good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy monday hope
everyone had a splendid weekend jackie
was your weekend splendid it was
splendid it was very busy
being
a tv junkie what does risk blended mean
something else um i watch so much tv
this weekend so i feel like you and i
finished obx i finished obs i have so
much to talk about i mean we have so
much to talk about because like last
night was the night of television oh my
god and i didn't even get to everything
because i also forgot that the season
finale of shots of sunset was last night
i couldn't get to it i was dead no we
had four hours plus because white lotus
was more than an hour of content to
watch and it was just overwhelming plus
i watched season two of obx this weekend
so many thoughts mostly i just want to
read all the texts that i sent you
throughout my journey of watching it
totally all of the plot holes that just
i i can't
i can't not see the moronic nature of so
many characters was really infuriating
really infuriating but other than that
my weekend was good it was bruce
birthday yesterday and we had a little
celebration for him some of the nibs
came over claudia came over and it was
just he was feeling really special in
love good good and i'm just so proud of
him i realized this morning that i said
i was going to bring him today but thank
god i didn't because it is sweltering in
here we're always complaining that it's
too cold the ac broke i'm literally like
this is my worst nightmare realized it's
so hot and there's no air circulation i
feel like you know how they say you
can't leave like a person in a hot car i
feel like we're currently in a hot car
it's so hot in here i actually did feel
something coming out of the way i was
just gonna say that's just like
not super cold so i uh of course you
know lodged a complaint like an official
maintenance
request and i do kind of feel like
there's air anyone else or maybe i'm
literally having a mirage no i think
there's something coming out of there
but it's just not doing what it usually
does we could always open a window if
need be like you're not in a car but no
i'm in a car
is my face really red i feel like i'm
actually going to faint not to be do you
have water
yeah right here okay yeah i have a
bottle of water to help us get through
the show i'm wearing like a gray long
sleeve oh no you could stay in you're
ready
i'm [ __ ] um i'm actually really
excited to be back here on the toes more
level-headed
um than i was on friday because
you know i got some negative feedback
from my episode on friday because i
think that like i was too hungover like
i was not functioning you know and like
you really were just like babysitting me
and i really apologize for that you get
negative feedback like one to one like
in your dms or like in common like a lot
everywhere you know like because i just
wasn't even speaking english i wasn't
functioning as a human being so i
understand
the frustration i do and like hangovers
are funny until they really impact like
i wasn't even speaking like i don't even
know what i was saying honestly so i
just i'm really excited to be back here
like fully alive i'm excited to have you
back fully alive um i do miss those
skeleton pants though i just had kept
looking at pictures of them on my phone
over the weekend and laughing i tried to
get you a pair as like a present
can't find them they're literally a
collector's item or maybe they're not
going to be back until the halloween
season i don't really want to hear about
the gifts that i didn't get and i just
ordered you a new gift oh my god so did
i re for you or for me for you oh my god
i wonder what it is it's really good i
think yours is really good but it's
custom so it was mine don't tell me i
ordered the same thing okay stop
that would be crazy that would be crazy
tell me what website you ordered it from
i don't know oh okay like
funkadelics.com okay okay no but like it
was
i i can't tell you because i will give
it away no i don't want to know
okay
what website do you order it from am i
telling you
that would be so crazy we're just out
gifting each other i read the craziest
thing last week speaking of halloween
that i need to share with the class
which is that you know it's almost
halloween spirit halloween and we'll be
popping up all over the city once again
including in former barneys
you're kidding isn't that insane
okay so for those who don't know in the
city there's not really any year-round
costume stores because it's well yeah
like ricky's they're costume stories
ricky's there haven't been a rickey's in
the city in like 10 years there might be
one last one on the upper east side
there are no real pieces to go to
ricky's is the spot there have been
there's also a costume store in um okay
there's like two in
astrophysics yeah eighth street yeah
okay but there's not like a million
whatever so what they do is like there's
this company called spirit halloween and
they do pop-ups for like three months
two months i saw my local spared
halloween getting started it's getting
started it's revving up so
they do pop-ups and they just use like
all these pop-up locations so you're
telling me that the former department
store to the stars home of
fred siegel
is doing fred's is doing
a pop-up
the barney's store front will be used as
a spare at halloween if you wanted to
understand the state of new york city so
sad and so sad when i saw it oh but you
know they got girls got to eat yeah damn
that's depressing
yeah i thought you would think so well i
can't what are you going to be for
halloween oh we actually actually just
settled on our halloween costume for the
toast it's pretty [ __ ] spectacular
it's pretty genius and i just like
because i'm so annoying have to say like
i did come up with it it was claudia's
idea so if you don't like it you know
who to talk to
and if you do like it you know who to
talk to you know what's so crazy is like
every year we're like oh my god we're
never going to be able to top what we
did last year and every year like we
really kind of hit it out of the park
we're due for like a flop you know yeah
i don't think this is it also like it's
not even about what we're dressed up as
it's what we bring to the table and how
like our spin on the characters right so
like your kind of teenage angsty spin on
prince harry was you know
acting genius yeah i think it was like a
bit of a revelation for some people and
also now knowing like what we know about
harry was pretty on the money pretty
brother grand grand
um so get excited for our toast
halloween 2021 hour fourth halloween
right
fifth
fifth if you include the breath you have
to include the breath it was the best
episode of all time yeah and since that
footage no longer exists one of these
days we should redo it no it was like it
didn't end well oh yeah i mean like we
were both offending each other but the
content was supreme i will never you'll
never never okay i will never step back
into your shoes okay okay
um we have a great show literally just
have so much tv to talk about not much
happened in the pop culture world over
the weekend but that's fine because we
have obx we have love
island you guys it's not love island
it's love
island
with a grimace on my face i don't even
have the words for how i'm feeling about
what transpired last night
i feel defrauded yeah i feel like taken
advantage of i
i feel angry yeah
i don't know i just i have so much anger
bottled up in me over what happened on
the show
we'll get to it but i i
i don't even know like i just feel i
don't even have the words do you know
what i mean you're speechless no
yeah it's like usually i'm so angry and
so i'm just gonna like let them know my
thoughts i will let you know my thoughts
but like this sort of anger just has me
silent and this is your official spoiler
alert for the entire episode we're
recapping outer banks
real housewives of potomac the white
lotus season finale that aired last
night and the love island season finale
that aired last night if you haven't
watched any of those things do not come
crying to me that we spoiled it okay
literally on the instagram last night i
was very particular not to spoil
anything but i wanted to announce you
know i want to get people's thoughts on
white lotus and you need to get the
pictures in order for today's speed and
so for love island i posted the
love island
the posted carousel the first picture
was just like the poster for the show
and then i said swipe to see the winner
and the amount of people who were like
you spoiled it you swiped you spoiled i
will say instagram has a glitch where
sometimes like when you're scrolling
through your feed it brings you to the
second photo i've never seen that in my
life like if you were on someone else's
carousel and you left it on like the
second photo you didn't scroll back to
number one like sometimes when you
scroll through the rest of your feed if
there's another carousel it starts you
on number two it's a really bad glitch
so i understand how that happened for
people but you know what like it's not
like it was a big um suspenseful evening
and we saved you two hours i just want
to say i've never heard or seen that
glitch oh okay i i have that glitch
sometimes but we saved you two hours so
actually you're welcome i'm having this
new glitch where like if i want to
upload something store something to my
story for my camera roll like one in
every five
will not post it just goes automatically
red oh interesting and then like you
have to delete it re-upload it will not
go like the file is corrupt and
instagram will not recognize it yeah
that happens to me too sometimes so
annoying so annoying but usually when
there's a glitch
i guess you have to vocalize it
someone's got to say something and then
they fix it really quickly yeah i don't
think anyone's ever mentioned that
carousel glitch though until now watch
it's going to go away also like remember
when we were standing by the elevator
here in our studio um like a couple
weeks ago and you were just like being
funny and i was filming you and you were
like send me that tag me that was a
corrupt file i never got to upload it i
don't even remember like what it was but
that's disgusting it was disgusting yeah
it was i was being so funny yeah do you
know what i'm talking about yeah but i
forgot what i was doing me too
hysterical but i was like in the uber
trying to upload it's like red red red
it's like [ __ ] off oh that's so annoying
so annoying
all right wait i just wanted to ask you
of everything that we watched last night
what was your favorite
most enjoyable thing honestly the real
housewives of potomac it was really it
was really good for me it was white
lotus okay i mean i really
let's just breathe through the stories i
have so much to say and i don't want to
spoil it stories are breezy but we need
to get like a stop clock because we
should give three minutes to each story
that's how nothing they are yeah but you
know sometimes the nothingness comes to
an amazing tangent i know and like when
we wanted to it always can but i want to
get to the [ __ ] tv recap me too
because like today's episode's literally
just going to be called the tv recap
show yeah so without further a do to
miss you
it is time for the moment of silence
moment of silence for dude's absence and
bruce absence i lied again
it is time for the five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
skylight frame staying in touch with
those we love is more important than
ever and the easiest way to do it is
with a skylight frame a photo frame you
can email photos to any time from
anywhere it's a great gift for someone
with a birthday coming up someone who
just had a baby or even for yourself
basically anyone can send photos to the
frame in just seconds so it's a great
way to keep in touch with friends and
family keep them up to date on how
you're looking how the kids are growing
it's really thoughtful and it's very
effortless to use the setup can take
less than 60 seconds and even the least
tech savvy person can use it it looks
like a real photo frame and it adds a
beautiful touch to your home and has a
gorgeous 10 inch touchscreen where you
can swipe through photos with your
finger and even tap to thank the person
who sent a photo
the skylight frame has 100 satisfaction
guaranteed if you don't love it they
will offer you a full refund you can tap
the heart button and let the sender know
you loved your photo so it's just great
for someone especially it's really not
that hard technologically to set up so
like for a mom or a grandma grandpa it's
really really thoughtful and even a
non-tech savvy person can set it up and
use it so when you go to
skylightframe.com use the code toast if
you want to get ten dollars off of uh
your purchase of a skylight frame so
it's skylightframe.com code toast
s-k-y-l-i-g-h-t-f-r-a-m-e
dot com code toast this is a great
solution because we were just talking
about how like if you walked into my
house you would literally never know who
lived there because like for so long i
didn't have like any pictures of my
friends or family and now instead of
buying like 30 frames i just have one
yeah a little slideshow it's such a
great gift too
so think about that if you want to get
me something called oh okay for the gift
that didn't arrive okay first story
which i found to be like the most
interesting story of the day um in the
celebrity world travis barker flies for
the first time since his deadly plane
crash travis barker has gotten on a
plane for the first time since his
deadly 2008 plane crash according to
photos obtained by tmz the blink 182
rocker and his girlfriend kourtney
kardashian flew to cabo on saturday
photos show the hot and heavy couple
leaving la in kylie jenner's private jet
also known as kylie air and also
deplaning once they landed safely in
mexico the owl reports that momager
chris and corey gamble were also on
board so this is really really big a lot
of travis fans know that due to the
accident he got into in 2008 he has not
flown since him and courtney are always
on the bus tour bus and like when he
goes to europe he does uh the qe2 like
he will go out of his way not to travel
on a plane because in 2008 he was in the
plane crash that killed dj am no
two other people him and dj am survived
in a year later dj am died of an
overdose right right um but he
was in the hospital for like years doing
skin grafts his skin was super burned it
was like an incredibly traumatizing
moment for him and of course he's never
been on a plane again right um but you
got to go to cabo so i guess courtney
gave him the strength to try again
and you know i just feel like there's so
many things about this story that are so
great like anyone overcoming their fears
is a beautiful thing it really is um but
the just the little details are so
heartwarming one that they flew kylie
air because you know that's like the
most premium [ __ ] plane right and
like you know kylie definitely it's so
special for them yeah do you think they
had to pay for it i'm just curious i
think they had to pay for like the gas
and the hanger fees like she's not just
like giving away free rides but not as
much as they would pay to charter from
like charter.com right their own charter
yeah and first of all i love that cory
and chris were there i just feel like
they're the exact type of person people
i would want to overcome a fear with
like so supportive yeah and two this
article is from tmz so i feel like it's
straight from chris jenner's mouth um
and they had a lot of really interesting
details like
travis was two hours late for the flight
unclear whether that's delays or he was
just like having second
guesses yeah second thoughts or you know
maybe he's a late person yeah so it was
just like so it's just like crazy to see
travis and like his vibe next to the
kylie air cleaning pink plane totally
it's just really like
beautiful and knowing that it's like
this major moment and them as a couple
like are overcoming so much together
it just brings a tear to the eye i know
i'm curious how he can really enjoy his
trip because he has to fly back home as
well unless
he's taken the tour bus but i don't know
like i just feel like he wouldn't really
be able to enjoy himself because he has
like this big hurdle coming up at the
end of the trip right where he has to
get back on the plane but maybe he has a
plan in place for if he say like the way
there he didn't feel good about it he
definitely has like a plan an uber yeah
yeah an uber rental hertz car
to drive can you drive from cabo i
believe that you can because it's like
you drive up the
strip
and then you just keep driving to
california going from california to
mexico no from la to cabo is like going
from new york to florida so i guess you
could drive it would take like a day
yeah but you could do it so i wonder why
he didn't just take the tour bus um
i don't know maybe it was time maybe it
was time yeah so i just think that
that's
such a beautiful story i hope they're
having an amazing trip i would have
loved to have been a fly on the wall on
the inside of that plane like what was
going on
were they doing like breathing exercises
was he freaking out the whole time was
he able to relax did they have a drink
like what what went on i don't know
we're i'm sure there were good snacks
you know kylie always provides only the
best for kylie air yeah
that plane is so sick so sick also news
courtney cut her hair
yeah
not my favorite i love when the girls
have short hair i really like i just
love short hair and i'm just like
waiting for the day where i go back to
mine but i love when kim has it i love
when kylie has it i love when chloe has
it i don't and
now courtney has it and so i'm digging
it i'm such a staunch long hair girl
i know that it really just goes against
everything i believe in but i feel like
whatever they're like you always say for
me
you always tell me to go back to my bob
i just want to say i haven't said that
in a while and i have changed my
thoughts on it what changed when i like
looked back at pictures i'm like it was
so cute back then but like you just look
better now huh
makes you think are you
sweating because like i'm moments from
fainting no i haven't broken the
prosperity you're kidding mm-hmm i'm
staying dry but i'm every fiber of my
being
yo like litter
back of my hair do you see it's
glistening oh my god no you don't look
like you're sweating okay like this is
where we have literally been left to
podcast in a hot car yeah so we're gonna
just have to move faster
i don't want to rush because you know we
really had such a bit about friday's
episode like not leaving it all out on
the table we're not rushing
to like just for tv recap okay
what
we both needed a second to pause
to drink some water because we're
overheating
oh you know when people get like hot and
they have like white crusties on their
lip
go away okay go away with your crusty
sorry
okay next up cute reunion news
jason momoa and amelia clark get
together for a game of thrones reunion
they posted an adorable series of photos
while celebrating game of thrones
creator david benioff's birthday a month
early it's when i say we're celebrating
his birthday
it is nice that they were celebrating
it's really really nice this picture of
the two of them is really cute like i
love she looks so teeny tiny she looks
so teeny tiny i love their love for each
other obviously if you watch game of
thrones here we have khaleesi and cal
drogo they were otp until you know they
weren't they weren't and it does look
like she's wearing my flats i just
wanted everyone to know oh my god she's
wearing your white used flaps she looks
like no she looks like she has them in a
lighter like a pale pink pale pink um so
i believe that they're nicholas kirkwood
like the heel looks the same and i just
feel extremely vindicated because even
if they're not exactly the same shoe the
style it's the same style and she chose
it and it's good enough for kyle drovo
wow that's actually a really interesting
thing you pointed out i didn't notice
that i noticed it but i i didn't want to
like comment because on the picture and
like draw attention to my flats you know
why because everyone's just like no
everyone has like knocked me down so
then stop wearing them i can't there you
go with everything
they go with everything let me ask you
another question i thought you got a new
pair it's not that the flats are ugly
they're just a little worn out okay i
didn't get a new pair of white
versions but i got them in
um like a nudie pink i have so
sometimes when white doesn't match i can
wear that color and why won't you just
get a new pair of white
um they're expensive honestly they're
like a really fancy shoe they're still
sold at bergdorf's i bought them like
three years ago and they're still in
style so
tell it to linda
who's linda a curator
um okay i just think there's nothing
wrong with the shoes just that they're
like take them to a shoemaker they're
just like black at the top and like
dirty okay but that's not what people
are complaining about i just want you to
know they don't like the style they
don't like the vibe and they just i
don't want to see me wearing dino
stompers or something it's not going to
happen i don't know how you deal with
the backlash
it's really hurtful when something's so
important to you um back to call drogo
and khaleesi every time these two are
together like i literally just want to
like die of happiness it's just so
joyous yeah and kind of like even though
i know he and his mama are in love
i do ship like in irl no i agree even
though i know there's like no hope for
any of this but like they really do give
us everything that we could ask for like
even these captions like when your son
and stars rolls into town you check that
he can still bench presa khaleesi and
then he said moon of my life you are
wonderful love you forever no they
literally talk on instagram like
cosplaying as khal drogo and kalisi and
they give the fans what they want they
give the fans everything yeah and i i
say this all the time but like when
people who reject the thing that made
them famous yes it bothers me so much
like they just try and act like that
thing didn't exist and they just want to
and i understand probably wanting to
move on with your life but it's so
annoying and i just love that kyle drogo
and khaleesi are giving us everything
and literally anytime i see two people
from game of thrones like no matter who
they are in the same room it's like the
best day of my life yeah also when you
see two of them in the same show
in the same room like when i was
watching medici and we had
rob stark in the same room as walder
frey he was marrying his daughter
shook that's crazy really yeah really
crazy and also seeing game of thrones
characters like acting and other things
or even just like out in the real world
none of them look like themselves like
the way that they were like in hair and
makeup and the outfits in game of
thrones is so bizarre looking because
you see them on a red carpet gwendolyn
christie like two different people yeah
it's really shocking even khaleesi she's
probably the like the biggest
now we're used to her being like
khaleesi versus amelia clark but like
the wig and like the everything yeah
it's just it was crazy it was a crazy
time honestly the person who probably
looks these are
sansa
yeah but sophie turner looks just like
sansa yeah but she has blonde hair now
sansa's red hair yeah but like for a
while like even outside of the show she
still had red hair yeah no i would say
jason mama was the one who looks like
his character the most of course yeah
um anyway so it's just like really cute
news for all you throners out there that
is cute are you ready for our next story
sure liam michelle is showing support
for beanie feldstein's buddy
she said you are the greatest star i
mean she had to say something yeah lea
michelle is joining other celebrities
and showing her support for beanie
feldstein following the news that she is
cast as fanny bryce in the funny girl
revival on broadway feldstein shared the
announcement on her instagram page last
week captioning her post i went to my
third birthday party dressed as fanny
bryce so sometimes dreams actually come
true that's cute in the comments section
various stars celebrated the good news
including leah michelle who said yes you
are the greatest star this is going to
be epic
i mean homegirl had to say something
just because literally the name on
everyone's lips was lea michelle um and
she had to be the bigger person and she
had to just be magnanimous um
but she's dying inside like i don't i
don't know that for a fact but i know it
for a fact
yeah what no i just like
i just sometimes feel like when there's
just such like an obvious narrative out
there that it's not true that's possible
you know what i mean yeah
so
like i don't know how this all went down
i i just feel like it's not as like
exactly how we think it is i know but
like how can we michelle not be upset i
don't know
yeah
that's like if they put together an
influencer ready if they put together an
influencer
play and they were doing hairspray and
they gave
tracy turnblad to someone else like
that's the role i was well not really i
don't feel connected to that you know
what i mean like something so obvious
yeah
i would be devastated yeah and she's
known to be like a diva
yeah
you're right
woke up today
feeling the way
i always do
oh
hungry for something that i can eat then
i hear that beat
the moon rhythm of town
it's like a message
and the streets that i love good morning
baltimore
every day's like an open door
every night is a fantasy
every sounds like a symphony
i love you boys
i've never you're doing so good i don't
think i've ever maybe you should be
tracy and some day when i take to the
floor the world's gonna wake up and see
baltimore
and me
we need a saxophone no you're so penny
pendleton if they put together so penny
channels okay if they put together like
an influencer cast to do
hairspray because they're like that's
fun to cast okay link larkin
link lark and i need to think of like
influencers i mean
is it influencers who are actors or just
like straight up like youtubers
podcasters straight up or youtubers
podcasters so link larkin like
nick vile
total no
no i i was honestly gonna say like greg
sulkin but then he's like an actor oh no
but like he's also an influencer so he's
yeah right he could be is that good but
he's also an actor but sure okay greg
sulkin
me and you as tracy and penny obviously
um amber oh amber
[Laughter]
that would like i don't think anything
would garner like more negative feedback
i could have feedback than that 100 but
not if we knock it out of the park you
could do it i mean i could do it i'm not
worried i can do anything i set my mind
to i can't believe
i believe that too it's just a matter of
setting my mind to it right and like
deciding do i want to set my mind to
this or not is this worth setting my
mind to such a good call
are you ready for our next story only if
it's a story that's brought to you by
away
it is it's actually
the perfect sponsor for this next story
because these next people are going away
away is a modern lifestyle brand that
creates thoughtful products for every
traveler and every kind of trip they
started with the perfect suitcase
crafted with features that make travel
more seamless and now when travel looks
more different than ever before you can
always count on a ways range of
suitcases bags and accessories whenever
you take that trip whether you're just
going to the corner store or a week and
away we are navigating the current
reality of travel but no matter what
your destination or style aways
suitcases bags and accessories come in a
variety of color sizes and materials to
suit your needs so all of their
suitcases if you have an away suitcase
you know that they're just like supreme
i have two and they're the best thing
i've not used a single other suitcase
since i got my away suitcase they're
designed to last a lifetime they have
durable exteriors and they can withstand
even the roughest of baggage channelers
each suitcase comes with an interior
organization system that includes a
built-in compression pad to help you
pack more and a hidden and removable
laundry bag that separates your dirty
clothes by the way
every way it's just like a little like
bag of tricks did you know first of all
i didn't for so long didn't know that
there was a laundry bag inside and it's
the best thing ever and they all come
with a um it's like a magic eraser so if
your bag gets like scuffed up you just
buff it out it's so smart um and the
wheels are 360 degree spinner wheels
that guarantee a smooth roll even in the
most hectic of airports and they're
available in different materials like
polycarbonate aluminum and durable nylon
and they have a ton of different sizes
and colors and it's a tsa approved
combination lock so all of your things
stay safe if any part of your suitcase
breaks their standout customer service
team will arrange to have it fixed or
replaced and there's a 100-day trial on
everything away makes so you take the
product out on the road live with it
love with it travel with it and you have
100 days to decide if it's for you or
not and you can return any
non-personalized item for a full refund
during that period so they also offer
free shipping and returns on any order
within the contingents us uk
europe and canada start your 100 day
free trial and trap the entire away
lineup of travel assession essentials
including their best-selling suitcases
at awaytravel.com
toast that's awaytravel.com
toast thank you so these ladies are
going to need their away suitcases
because gerinda medley and vicky
gumbelson have been tapped for a real
housewives mashup series
so it's like another all-stars another
all-stars except this is like the b team
literally so they're doing another
crossover series with all housewives but
they're all former housewives so we have
dorinda oh that's sad
jill zarin oh brandi glanville oh
phaedra parks oh taylor armstrong ooh
eva marcel okay honestly it sounds like
it's not really a b team but it's like
the best of the best of former
housewives right but emphasis on the
former yeah so it's still not as
prestigious i mean that one with like
kenya cynthia kyle
who else
who from new york went luanne
ramona ramona that one is gonna be so
[ __ ] sick you know what it will be
but i wouldn't be surprised if this
speed team is better because they have
nothing to lose and so much to me and so
much to gain yeah they do a really good
job if like they become the fan favorite
from this series like they could get
back on their own show i mean honestly
i've been saying this for a while i do
feel like a a
pretty decent
improvement to the flailing real
housewives of new york franchise would
be to bring jill zara back but she has
said i don't know if it's true but she
said she wouldn't do it she said she
wouldn't yeah on watch robin's live um
that's when they were doing all that
special why why wouldn't she she just
said she wouldn't but she would do this
she said she wants to be cast as a
friend of but she would do this yeah i
mean that's like a one-time thing i
guess i don't know i don't know it seems
like a heavier lift i have to imagine
she would love to do it yeah and by the
way i rewatched real houses of new york
during covid
and i think the narrative around jill's
aaron is so unfair like she put she put
the show on the map she was everything
at the time like so funny
she didn't drink so she was really just
like making the show work
naturally like she wasn't just getting
wasted and saying crazy things her
marriage was so great she really laid it
all out with ally like i'm sure allies
traumatized her all that stuff but like
she really
she was
it she was yeah and i think she was an
amazing reality star and she got [ __ ]
because she
made some bad decisions when it came to
the whole bethany thing in the world
took bethany side but it's been so long
i do think like the show could actually
really
benefit from her she was great yeah i
don't disagree with that it could
benefit from really anything yeah
anything would help anything would help
um so i'm excited for whatever this is
whenever it comes out obviously i'll see
the other one first yeah
just really an interesting programming
choice yeah when is that other one
coming out they filmed it a while ago
yeah i don't know probably in the winter
and you think it's like like six
episodes like how many yeah i don't
think it's long i think it's super short
me too i wonder what goes down no i know
i feel like
it's gonna be great yeah it will be
now our fifth and final story which is
going to lead into our tv recap it is
the love island finale we have our
winners spoiler alert from here on out
the winners of love island season three
are olivia and corey
you know what
when they were down to the final two and
it was willing here and olivia and corey
i was begging begging for it to be will
and kira because you want to know why
there's definitely some toxic things
going on in that relationship but a lot
of relationships are toxic and that is
still a real relationship um i did think
it was odd how like in this episode they
were just like talking about this whole
experience and how they never would have
met
each other and he's like can you believe
we live 15 minutes away from each other
we never would have known it's like you
do
yeah you didn't know that no yeah that's
part of the theory as to why they
had met before and i guess if producers
think that they met before then they
like really couldn't have won but like
at least will and kira there is love
there even if it's not on both sides and
it's not exactly as balanced as it
should be and who knows what's going to
happen after this like she has fallen in
love in love island olivia has
amateurly acted her way through the
whole season i can't i
i saw a posting just after dark that
like some people have fallen for the
charade and they really think olivia i
believe that some people have fallen for
it i can't i can't believe it i really i
really cannot the whole episode was
olivia and quarry propaganda yes and
trying to like show us this love story
and justice for cory because he's not
acting i think he's like so happy with
olivia and this because if he were
acting
he would have taken all the money for
himself of course as by the way i wish
he did
first of all he should have ran with the
money first of all but he can't see what
we see second of all once olivia opened
her envelope and she had the zero
dollars i knew it was over because of
course he was going to share it with her
because he really is in love with her
whereas like honestly if olivia had
gotten the 100 000 she might have taken
it for herself i know you think that i
think she still would have split it
because i think she really cares what
people think about her and she doesn't
want to prove everyone right that she
was acting this whole time she wants to
go out like you know like the person
she's pretending to be the whole time
she's not going to let the match it's
worth fifty thousand dollars to her for
people to think that like her and cory
are in love and that she's a and i'm
sure that she is a good person i think
she just like saw she got caught up in
this thing and just like wanted to see
it through and stay on the show and get
the instagram and she just got like so
lucky that everyone else was a real
couple dropped away and we're sort of
left with these two so it all started
the propaganda i mean it's been going on
for weeks but it all started at the
challenge last night which i know you
fast forwarded through i did because
there was so much tv on and i found the
challenge is so boring but my theory was
confirmed when they had to do all this
stuff to get you know whoever had the
shortest time in the wedding challenge
would get the honeymoon suite and
there's three cakes that they each have
to go through with their mouths to find
two flamingos in three cakes to put them
as wedding toppers and
bailey and jeremy went and bailey is
literally head butting her head against
this cake to crack it open to get a
flamingo out like they she wants to hide
away really she wants to hide away so
badly and i just love bailey and jeremy
so much like
jeremy went from being my absolutely
favorite not understanding why nobody
would save him to literally being so
upset that he came in third and really
feeling like a lot of the results had to
have been rigged oh by the way the thing
is rigged i
i need to see evidence that it's not
because it is like the way that it went
that's just not what happened i really
think so many people voted for bailey
and jeremy just because they were
the least worst couple and they towards
the last couple episodes they had the
most growth and like their editing i
don't know if it was the editing but i
was like getting really like in my
fields i'm like they're so great but
then jeremy was finally giving us what
we've been asking yes
he finally felt comfortable and like now
i don't fault him this whole time for
being sort of friendly with girls when
they're day two of being a couple no
totally and the second i turned on last
night's episode i knew that olivia and
corey were winning every time they just
got like a different kind of edit a
different music that whole thing back to
the challenge so bailey is literally
head butting this cake she wants it so
bad olivia and cory get to the stage of
having to go through the cake and
olivia's standing there while corey does
it she will and she literally takes one
bite out of the side of the cake like
she how did they win
i don't know like they didn't show us
anyone's time rigged rigged like they
didn't show us anyone's time and it's
just like at the end olivia and quarry
won because like the network needed to
give them this honeymoon sweet date and
then the next morning when they're like
standing out on the balcony like looking
out like a bachelor couple like
propaganda also when they were between
the sheets in the highway scene i called
clock
you don't understand i'm literally like
pointing out every single thing so it's
nighttime scene we have the three
couples in the villa who are all pulling
up the covers and getting frisky oh yeah
first of all there was like nobody in
the main room so there's only three beds
they were all pretty far apart like
everyone [ __ ] everyone was getting
frisky as [ __ ] and like we saw some of
it and then the covers went up you know
like bailey and jeremy wow yeah
we
cut to olivia and corey who immediately
pulled the covers up we don't see [ __ ]
between them and then i i believe that
they were under the covers like this
just trying to make it seem trying to
make it look like something and by the
way in the morning when everyone asked
olivia she didn't say like shannon told
the girls that she had sex in the
highway like they're all best friends no
in the morning when she had to say how
the villa went like i'm sorry her her
mask was slipping yeah we had fun
the thing is is that like the episode
really made me really like all the
couples except olivia and corey like
even will and cara like i can get past
it like they're toxic whatever but i
don't know they're they are a couple and
charlie and elena i was like oh my god
like obsessed like just the episode was
just edited to make you root for
everyone except for olivia and corey and
i when they said jeremy and bailey in
third place like i knew it was over i'm
like are you [ __ ] serious oh my god i
was so i screamed i was so heartbroken
and shocked and i just had to sit there
and like watch it take it take it and
watch it go down there's nothing we
could do it was so
so upsetting like
everything is just a lie
a lie and so
i just feel like first of all it's so
crazy we were left with four couples and
50 of them got that got here one week
ago like that's the craziest part like i
think will and kieran no matter how many
we feel about them they were always
going to be in the top four they were a
legit couple and it is love island it's
not friendship island so like even
though trina and andre
went home and i was bad like they had no
they hadn't no it's not violent and i
love trina
right totally
um
it was just so frustrating that we ended
like
all the other cast mates like
kashay and trina and giovanni and
shannon and cinco they were all on live
and like i would rather watch this live
than this episode like i just love so
many of the people who are no longer
there and just like seeing cash and
cinco even though i do blame cash for
her and cinco not
being in the final four because she
chose charlie even though she heard she
knew her feelings for cinco she's like
the fact that cash and cinco are
together at home and not in the villas
so stupid obviously shannon and josh
couldn't be there but like we needed
them like it was just felt like such a
stitched together finale it was so
so bad like what a waste of
the whole like all of our time and and
everything invested because i just feel
defrauded i i do i want to see i just
wish
i don't know i i don't know how they
could even prove to us that it was true
i know and not that they care did you
also feel like the whole money splitting
thing was so informal like nobody would
ever actually take it because because
ariel was like
oh what are you gonna do like it wasn't
even like a official ceremony he was
like obviously like it was just a
conversation yeah that's always how it
is it would just be like anyone ever
taken the money not on u.s okay but i
don't know about uk but it'll be like if
someone came in here like say will won
and he's the kind of person where it's
like is he being genuine this whole time
and say he was actually not a genuine
person i don't i'm not saying that he is
but like that's where would be like the
answer he could keep the money and it
would just go to show that like every
feeling that you had about him was right
yeah yeah i mean he really thought he
was waiting like this smile on his face
when ariel was like going five four
three two one he thought he was winning
so hard and first of all i've been like
reading reddit but i guess i've been
missing out because love island
twitter's so funny you told me to go
read it i was
cackling first of all everyone is like
feels like we've been frauded by olivia
and corey like they're not buying them
and that's that makes sense why they
took all those tweets because people on
twitter are so invested and they don't
believe olivia and corey like yeah or
olivia olivia yeah corey i really stand
by that corey is a nice guy and i do
feel like he loves olivia no and also
when they were in their confessional
after the challenge and he put the
cupcake in her eye like you could see
for a second she was like
i'm just saying watch it all back you
guys watch it like you could see for a
second that she was like so angry but
then she had to like mask up right and
be like
like
and then she did her like scream thing
that cache that she's still from cafe
yeah yeah and claudia i'm just telling
you i see through it all
that's so funny you can't fool me you
can't
do they have a reunion no because this
was two days ago what's to reunite about
with everyone else like they don't they
should
they could because indian west are
[ __ ] pissed but like a lot of
reunions it's like okay what has
happened since then in the last six
months this was two days ago i don't
know i just feel like a reunion wouldn't
be the least interesting thing no but
like also like everyone's like just a
little disgruntled like and also there's
something felt like they were ready to
go the [ __ ] home everyone was like i
don't even care if i went i need to get
out of here there's not that much like
sabotage on the show so it's not like
things work wrong aside from like will
like here are finally watching the
footage it's not like people are seeing
things that like
now they need to hash it out everyone
really is like nice to each other and
who they are to their faces who they are
behind their backs um can we also just
really briefly talk about the dresses
because they were so [ __ ] heinous
except for bailey's was like not
terrible
somebody said that in the pictures from
from last night that olivia looked like
corey's mom like that dress was terrible
elena that dress was atrocious and
keira's was probably the worst like so
like prom dressed from the set from the
90s like
this is the cbs budget it was atrocious
and even all jeremy looks like a waiter
like everyone's
oh um will's like tuxedo it was just
terrible like everyone they looked like
clowns out there dancing giving their
fake wedding vows like it was clown [ __ ]
okay
the outfits were atrocious and i just
feel like whoever dressed elena like
really did her dirty yeah it was such a
such an ugly dress you saw her pick it
out herself
yeah sure i just want to say another
moment where the mask was slapping for
olivia
um when she like right before they
announced the winners and they all had
to like say some [ __ ] again olivia was
talking about like her journey and she
literally couldn't even muster up like
one thing she said something nice about
corey like this amazing man but like
nothing about her feelings for him it
was like this journey has been so
amazing i met so many amazing people
like i've learned so much about myself i
met this amazing man but like nothing
like and i'm you know nothing about
their relationship yeah no she was just
like being really gentle she couldn't
even muster up like a nice fake a nice
fake thing yeah i'm just really excited
to see how this plays out irl like
you're right like olivia is obsessed
with like being well-liked she wants to
be like popular with everyone um so how
long will she like realistically let
this charade last she lives in alaska
where does he live i don't know
there's just so much going on no and i
think
i really am curious to see where jeremy
and bailey go from here me too and he
lives in new york yeah he does and where
does she live i don't know
jeremy's so interesting like
it's been a roller coaster but like
that's how you should feel like
people yeah like he's really growing so
much i really think they deserve to win
we're willing and their vows were
hysterical not you getting everyone in
the villa to talk like this it was so
cute it was real and i'm a little afraid
that bailey likes him more than he likes
her because i do think he likes her but
like she's like obsessed i know but i
think he just plays it close to the vest
okay
so it was whatever like
um
i really enjoyed watching love island
for the first time i do feel like i
chose like probably the worst season to
start on because like it was so so so
good until it wasn't yeah so
it is what it is
it is what it is um that's our
first part of our tv recap but it does
not end here and the tv recap segment is
brought to you by canva pro making
content is an essential part of what we
do to keep our business going but it
hasn't always been a seamless creative
process if you scroll down on some of
our instagram posts from like the early
days of the toast it's just sad don't do
it um but ever since we found canva pro
we can design anything like a pro on any
device canva pro is a design platform
that empowers you to create and share
stunning content in just a few clicks
whether you're a design professional or
just getting started designing with
canva pro is amazingly fast and fun you
can choose from thousands of
professionally made templates that are
so easy to customize and um all you have
to do is simply drag and drop or start
from scratch canva pro comes with an
endless print amount of premium fonts
photos videos and so much more that add
personally and personality and edge to
whatever you're designing so you can use
shapes fonts there's images there's so
many things there's free stuff there's
stuff you pay for it's so premium if you
have a business and you're constantly
making content for social or for your
website really implore you to check out
canva pro it literally keeps this
business running um we we're built on
canva pro
sharing creating and organizing your
designs as a group has never been easier
because canva pro helps you stay on top
of team projects all in one place and
with their content planner you'll save
time planning creating and posting
social media content um
my favorite feature of canva pro is
probably just like the endless bounds of
assets like they have cute little
dancing arrows like just things to make
your instagram cute because it's 20 21
like you gotta get with the program so
design like a pro with canva pro right
now you can get a free 45 day extended
trial when you use our promo code just
go to canva.com sorry canva.me toast to
get your free 45-day extended trial
that's c-a-n-v-a
dot m-e
toast canva dot me slash toast
c-a-n-v-a
dot m-e slash toast thank you claudia
okay let's go to white lotus next okay
everyone was waiting the big reveal like
who gets murdered who gets murdered and
so now that we know in last night's
episode and you know everything happened
and it's going to be spoiler at some
point yeah first of all if you haven't
finished it turn this off now because
obviously armon ends up being the one
who gets killed by shane it appears to
have been an accident he doesn't get
arrested or anything because this man
was on the premises taking a dump in his
room no and like trespassing in his room
yeah i think just before we dive in we
really need to talk about the [ __ ]
okay because i was talking to my friend
abe okay and he like thinks like it was
our live action [ __ ] like it was no i
could see it coming from the back cheek
like you know
you thought it was special effects like
no i'm not i don't even think it was
that special i think there was like
someone feeding the [ __ ] like from like
you know from behind it's like
i can't really do it but like
like a push pop no yeah like it was
coming from his like side of his cheek
on the other side i know i know what
you're saying it's just more of a visual
illusion i felt it was so wild i've
honestly never seen and it was up there
with the pig and the prime minister
[ __ ] no no i did not need to see
someone taking a dump
no it was really crazy and then and then
they dumped in the suitcase no i i
thought they were going to spare us a
dump in suitcases i thought we were just
going to like see his face like you know
making a few pushing sounds like
not get the ass and the duty coming out
like it was so
vulgar i agree it's like so disgusting
and unnecessary um
which i don't know why they feel the
need to do stuff like that i guess
because like we're talking about it the
next day to be honest it made the show
ten times more interesting i was losing
my mind like screaming okay no when the
[ __ ] was happening i was like averting
my eyes i was like this is disgusting um
and then i was laughing so hard
when he found it when shane found it he
had to call downstairs and be like my
wife doesn't [ __ ] on the floor like
there's a turn in my room i hadn't
laughed that hard that the entire show
okay have you ever seen that wanda sykes
stand up yes there is a turd in my car i
used to watch out when i was in high
school all the time if you've ever seen
just google wanda sykes turd it is the
funny i think it's a stand-up bit i
don't know it's so [ __ ] funny
it reminded me so much that's a good
call yeah so i was like already feeling
i just like where it was going and i
mean
not seeing the [ __ ] but like just
shane's reaction to it was just so funny
and then he kills armani it is a little
like anti-climactic yes also like i
don't know i feel like in some shows
that we watch like someone gets stabbed
a million times and they like still are
fighting their way out and and our mom
was stabbed on his um right on the right
side like not by the heart even so yeah
well the thing is is that if you stab
someone you're not supposed to pull it
out because then all the blood comes out
and that's how you die you lose blood so
if he had left the knife in there and
like got an ambulance he probably would
have lived
got it but most people don't know that
just me oh that's good that you know
that okay so but can we talk about the
show like at a glance at a glance
because honestly i felt like there were
so many um
kind of
dumb story lines that like i thought
would get resolved like everything
happens for a reason but like there were
just all these things aside from the
woman having the baby what else the
woman having the baby that man who came
and sat next to jennifer coolidge at the
pool like what i was like what's new
character
even the son who like fell in love with
the ocean like i just didn't understand
i just want to say i called it weeks ago
that he had the most character
development agreed and when he ran off
the plane i was happy for him no and
like even when he but even before when
they were still on vacation he was like
coming back to the room with this you to
be even like he spent his day like
rowing in the morning scuba diving in
the afternoon when like when he arrived
connecting with his father on his
nintendo the whole time i was really
proud of him
and so i just didn't understand like
the point of so many of these characters
and so many of these story lines and i
don't
but then at the end i understood what
the show's kind of message was it's like
all these rich people just show up on an
island ruin the lives of kill people
ruin the lives of everyone who works
here and then just go on with their day
and the people who work there have to
take this emotional burden and then the
next day do it all again yeah new
annoying new annoying people i totally
get yes but the show was boring i agree
also like major justice for belinda like
that
when rachel's just going on and on about
this like shut up rachel rachel was just
the [ __ ] worst yeah you couldn't even
root for her and like what she was
trying to say it's like i'm even with
you it's valid i'm feel alone even when
i'm with you like very sad for rachel
yeah but like just she doesn't know who
she is she doesn't know what she wants
did she meet her husband on the wedding
day like how did she only fight he's he
was an [ __ ] like and you could see
within one second so like you dated this
man went through the wedding process and
like now you're upset and then you're
just going to go back i didn't
understand their ending at all i i i
guess she decided to stay with him um
maybe because he needed like a shoulder
after he accidentally killed someone
right um maybe because she like
just doesn't know what the [ __ ] she
wants that's what i think it's more of
um
but she just yeah she doesn't know who
she is or what she wants and like figure
it out totally and then i saw someone
commented on the toast and i don't know
if they were joking but it made actually
a really good call that that guy that
jennifer coolidge ends up with is like
covered patient zero
oh cause like we never
what was wrong with him he was coughing
the whole time
i saw that i didn't think that i thought
that was just like brings it back to
california no no no no but that's like
not how kobe started and um i thought it
was an interesting take no my take is
that he's like very much like brooks
like vicky and brooks and he's like
faking this illness so that like
jennifer coolidge will pay all of his
medical bills and she's about to be
swindled again and when she said to
belinda i can't like have another
transactional relationship it's like
well you're about to have one getting a
house in aspen and like doing all these
things for this guy like she's just
about to be like taken advantage of that
totally went over my head that's like
she thought she was breaking her pattern
but she's actually about to get even
deeper oh and like she really could
spend all that money on belinda because
like i would go to belinda's holistic
spa a hundred percent i feel like she
could really heal me a hundred percent
the
i just really did feel like the show was
so over hyped yeah and
so slow and at the end of the day boring
yeah and do you know who created the
show ned schneebley mr ned schneeblay
the guy from the actual niche you're the
actor from
school of rock he's the creator of the
show which is just an interesting
factoid so all in all i just did feel
like i got on the train because like
everyone was on it and even from the
moment i started the show i just like
thought it was slow and boring and i'm
glad i stuck with it because i do feel
like it was like an interesting take
but just from like a cinematography's
point of view like it was a boring show
yeah um i agree and i liked i enjoyed
watching it while i was watching it but
it's just like
we can all agree nothing happened
um
and like we never got an update with kai
yeah like did he go to prison
it's not good yeah and like did
she ever get her jewelry back she did
because no because armand said he would
get it back but then armand died in the
airport she was wearing it she was like
i think they were like marveling at her
bracelets okay i believe that's what i
thought i saw yeah and like honestly
paula like just
sit like having to be on a trip with
them like she was just like so missed
the whole time and that whole family was
just ms [ __ ] vibes the daughter of
what's her name olivia yeah the [ __ ]
woe she was the woe
except for quinn the son he was kind of
everything i'm telling you yeah but like
he's literally in hawaii without a cell
phone i know like what is the air zone
do you feel it
no no maybe it's a mirage again um yeah
like what is he gonna do for living
situation work i mean how does he get in
contact with his family he doesn't have
a phone yeah
it's like low-key dangerous yeah but i
love the kind of wanderlust spirit he
currently possesses yeah no and that
he's like interested in the world around
him did you see when like she told him
to get ready for dinner connie britain
he was in his little kitchen cot reading
a book on like marine biology or like
the ocean because he wasn't on his
computer he wasn't on his nintendo he
was reading a book and it looked like to
be about ocean life no like i want to
spin off about him 100 like do they end
up
rowing around to the island
where the
do they make it
we'll see we'll see um so closing the
chapter on that and opening up the real
houses of atomic which last night's
episode you know i'm getting
like deja vu from last season because i
feel like currently until ashley
actually gets to the house and spills
the beans that giselle was
bringing up the rumors about eddie like
we're kind of in this standstill and
like i just need her to get there and it
reminds me of last season when candace
like needs to tell ashley about the
michael darby stuff it's like
it's like the catalyst and like just get
there already so i thought we were gonna
get there tonight ashley doesn't even
arrive until next episode right but
what's crazy is it looks like in next
week's episode like ashley is like
getting a lot of [ __ ] from people for
bringing it up but like i hope that's
not where i know i thought i think that
was just editing because i refuse like
it's fully giselle it's fully giselle
but also it was interesting to see
gisele
trying to bring it up like she's
obviously going about it in like
multiple ways she's never gonna be so
overt as to be like you're acting this
way because of this that and the other
thing but like she's like
she's very conniving the fact that robin
and giselle are spending countless hours
thinking about what wendy's wearing is
shocking to me one because if gisele
spent literally one eighth of the time
thinking about what she wears maybe she
wouldn't be like the joke of the group
when it comes to fashion first of all
second of all robin your kids failing
school you're struggling so much with
your marriage and your mental health
stop worrying about wendy now i agree
there is something different with wendy
and i don't think it's this big
conspiracy theory i think that and i
like how they're like for the whole time
that i've known you you've only known
her since last year right and also wendy
reminded us that she was two months post
party and so i i i totally didn't put
that together so it kind of all does
make sense we don't know who wendy was
who wendy was before she had kids and
maybe she's you know finally getting
back to feeling like most herself
so i just feel like they're judging her
without cause i'm so jealous and when
gizelle used the word substance like
last season you had substance implying
that this season you don't it was just
all wrong so i want to say that like
there really is something very
interesting happening with wendy because
wendy's obviously turning hard and fast
on robin and giselle which is great i
love the cottage i would [ __ ] stay in
the cottage even though it's a piece of
[ __ ] like the fact that that candace
booked this trip knowing that like what
four women are staying in a palace and
three women are staying in like a
holiday inn is really not cool no and
also let me not forget that wendy is
candace's friend yes
so that's what i was going to say
candace brought wendy on but but
candace is standing up for wendy when it
comes to robin and giselle in her
confessionals and even in the room and
even though i literally despise candace
i do think that if she
stands with wendy and like the whole
group dynamic kind of change kind of
changes because this like threesome in
the cottage is like kind of everything
and then candace joins them and mia and
karen like and ashley and of course
ashley i do think it could finally be
like this robin and giselle isolating
moment that it needs to be because
they've always been like the cool group
and they're like getting all the new
girls and it's annoying but wendy's like
a really interesting target for them
because wendy brings candace with her
hopefully but candace didn't even bring
wendy into the house i know but i don't
think when wendy's thinking about it as
much as you are because candy candace
was defending wendy this entire episode
both in the house and in her
confessionals like she stands with wendy
okay okay just think about it that's
good to remember also i do really feel
for robin when she talks about um like
seasonal depression her seasonal
depression and like her personal life
and i think she's like starting to
realize that it's more like i think all
this time she probably was just like
being hard on herself like why can't i
do this as opposed to like no it's
getting there's no help for herself yeah
and just like
being easier on herself and realizing
like it's out of her control a little
bit and i just thought it was a really
nice conversation between all the women
and like except for gizelle except for
giselle and how but how they could all
relate to her and like you know whether
at what point in their life they were
going through something similar and like
i just feel like
that's the sort of conversation email
like camaraderie that
just what happens on all of these shows
once in a while and it's like
yeah that's really nice of course and
like can you could you die from like how
[ __ ] nasty giselle was being like as
if you could just fix depression like i
agree but giselle is robin's actual
friend like a real true friend and
sometimes like and i guess giselle's
version of
hoping is like tough love and just like
saying speaking her mind so i actually
think gisele and robin are close enough
for giselle to talk to her to say that
to her but i think for the rest of the
women it's just like looking like gisele
being an [ __ ] again yeah i mean it's
crazy to see all these women having more
compassion for robin than even her own
best friend even if that is you know
gisele's way of being compassionate
gisele is just so difficult to like and
honestly
[ __ ] escala i very much doubted her i
did and i think i underestimated her but
she's like well since you're asking
everyone so many questions human if i
ask you a question a very reasonable
thing to say like what's the status of
your relationship and of course giselle
question of i'm queen of like poking
people asking questions going too far
i'm not going to talk about that right
now in front of certain people but if
you want to ask me privately like she's
so
predictable at this point it's like sad
it's sad
i agree like
she's just full of
and the fact that karen hughes can like
sit around at all these like knowing
what she knows about gizelle and like
how she feels about gisele and just sit
and she's been like so quiet and
reserved and not like saying anything
she's a hero
because i would be up in arms i just
hope her time will come it's coming i do
i don't want to drink it but with the
eddie stuff you turned out to be exactly
who everyone said you were going to be
um
mia's like being kind of weird yeah like
she's not being karen strong enough you
know she's being very much like a
mediator like you don't know giselle
like at all
and like it's just it's kind of
disappointing because like did you see
her response on twitter last week when
someone was like how could you just let
like robin and gisele kick you out of
like the room she's like well you know
some people don't get nice things that
much so it's nice to let them experience
it like i have nice bedrooms and things
at home which is such a good response
right
i'm disappointed in her lack of
taking a side even though like i don't
think people should take sides but like
right now yeah no but i think listen
she's new
actually gisele and robin have been
nothing but nice to her really
and and sometimes you have to see for
yourself it must feel good to like come
into the group and these big mean girls
who like even your even karen like can't
get along with like they like you and
they want to be friends with you and
like she has no reason
to take a side right now i'm sure
eventually she will and based on that
tweet it's you know yeah it's already
happened it's team monique um
team [ __ ] money watching these
episodes just like knowing monique would
put everyone in their place it's so
especially giselle like it's so
frustrating knowing what we could have
had yeah so i think mia will come around
i'm not she we don't need her yet like
she because she's just too new like if
she just were to blindly support karen
it just would look like buying support
and that's kind of what wendy did with
candace last season and it was like it
was made me not like wendy right yeah
that's true well i do feel like tides
are turning and i'm just curious because
like you know wendy and
i'm no not wendy um giselle and robin
are like in the house with the cool
girls like does america support the
estate or the cottage i'm firmly team
cause i didn't look last night but i'm
firm i believe i believe team cottage
let me know in the comments over here on
youtube like are we team caught like
it's so obvious to me like they were
like they were in this like shitty
little cottage but they're having so
much fun and karen is like
i love how karen wasn't even bothered by
like the fact that her room was like 30
times grosser than the other estate
because she's like this room provides
peace this room is a sanctuary like
that's how you know you're with toxic
people when you would rather take like
the shitty ass room with people you feel
safe with than like being a palace with
robin and giselle yeah like i felt
that's so hard yeah i agree
so i do believe next week is when ashley
finally arrives i thought she was gonna
make it there tonight or and like start
stuff but she didn't um
and if ashley gets blamed like i'm
[ __ ] done yeah i'm [ __ ] done but i
do think wendy will be able to wendy's
smart see through it yeah
except like i just really can't like i'm
really wendy's really really grown on me
except when she talks about her candle
company well she didn't talk about it
last night i know so that's good yeah
um okay other thing that i watched this
weekend was obx oh right right right i'm
gonna go to my text messages with you
because it has pretty much all of my
thoughts so i
in the beginning was almost gonna stop
watching because when they're in the
bahamas it's just so stupid but when
they all meet up in charleston and then
go back to obx and like the gangs back
together it gets so much better
that's what i'm saying
okay i we text so much but because it it
became so infuriating to start to root
for the pogues because they're so dumb
chiara so dumb okay first by the way i
just want to say like you kept calling
me like after every like dumb thing that
happened and i did the exact same thing
to margo at the exact same time i said i
was done watching when kiara they
finally get the footage of the murder
and she's like
no no this is what i said i can't take
it seriously after carrier yelled
murderer from the rooftop and caused
them to lose all their footage they need
to kick her out of the friend group for
that if they don't i don't know if i can
keep watching not only did they not kick
her out of the friend group but i just
want to say they dragged greg was that
the name of the pilot
no it's like devon or something no it's
it's like grayson
whatever the pilot they dragged the
pilot out to me like they
gave him they got him killed
they got him killed
they took a video of it they lost the
footage and what's going on crazy gavin
and what's so crazy is like when they
were blaming each other for like who
made the camera drop they never once
even said for kiara for yelling murderer
no they're like you kicked it i'm like
well
that was the reason we weren't you guys
wouldn't have a toothless you could have
waited until he left the scene ward and
then you would have had this footage and
it would have been [ __ ] over um it
was so stupid i wanted to die then when
they get back and they said what these
pogs are morons i'm about to root for
war totally like they were making it so
hard to root for them like they wanted
to save john p but they were literally
just sabotaging themselves left right
and center left right and center then
all of a sudden kiara has to ask her
parents if she can go to charleston
these they literally never go home they
are out days at a time we never even
don't even know who their parents are
and now she has to get permission to go
to charleston obviously that was like
leading up to like this storyline about
her potentially going to boarding school
but like
now the obstacle is asking your parents
like totally what in the world yeah
then at one point i kind of shipped
topper and sarah so i called margaret
and i said the exact same thing because
he ended up like showing his true colors
like being a dick at the end but up
until that point he was taking better
care of sarah than john b was and
honestly like
sarah like sarah's the reason for like
sarah and jambi are the reason for like
this entire mess and at the end of the
day like they really never could be
together like we had thought because now
we know that zombie's dad is alive but
we had thought that like sarah's dad
killed john b's dad which is obviously
like terrible but he is still her dad so
like it's just literally too complicated
and they're really not realistically
ever going to be able to like be
together and what is so crazy is their
relationship is so strong they're
literally getting married when they're
like fleeing the bahamas with the police
on their tail like with nothing in this
world and they're like they couldn't be
in a better relationship and the one
minute they have a bit of peace because
ward um
unquote um
they break up yeah like when it's
finally good around them they they yeah
i guess maybe that's when they have to
realize like they're the differences
between them and they don't even get to
enjoy also these pokes every they're
literally running from the police
everyone wants to kill them there's
always this and the other thing they get
say three hours of a reprieve and
they're just getting drunk totally like
and then someone comes to try and kill
them and they're like hi and like
sinking in a tree and they're all high
and drunk yeah rafe is such a good actor
like he's so [ __ ] crazy but it's so
[ __ ] crazy it was really frustrating
that like and i'm a fairly family
oriented person of course but like the
lengths that ward and rose were going to
just to keep their family together
you have an actual sociopath living
under your roof and you have a young
daughter why doesn't anyone care about
weezy why doesn't anyone [ __ ] care
that rafe tried to kill sarah why didn't
they tell anyone no so this was that i
sent you next i said why don't topper
and sarah go to the police and say rafe
attempted to murder her they could have
charges pressed against him they could
have
they could have had him behind waters
before we ever knew that spoiler alert
ward was still alive
so what the [ __ ] it's like why didn't
she even tell her dad before he died
like he he he was like trying to really
like ignore the fact that rafe is a
serial killer like he didn't want really
to admit it but like sarah's his
favorite so
she goes over there thinking she could
talk to her dad she never told him rave
tried to kill her yeah i'm like what
these people don't want to win no but
sarah and topper it's not like it's
sarah and johnny and john b's always
like in trouble like they could have
gone
to the police
filed a complaint topper witnessed a
topper witnessed and they could he could
have been in jail for a few years
totally like it was so moronic and then
and then rafe wouldn't have been able to
get the cross i knew it was pretty
predictable like the second that rose um
opened the door and saw that letter like
i pretty much knew ward was still alive
because first of all he's like such a
main character and he's too selfish like
he has so much on the line the cross the
gold he's not just killing himself like
he's coming and he said like you have to
trust me trust me so i knew that he was
going to be alive and i knew that he was
going to be on that boat um
but i do feel like i've been able to
call some other things that um let's
just wait let's finish recap and then i
want to tell you my call then i also
wanted to say that given the
relationship that john b and sarah had
they were like husband and wife um john
b would have never talked to that random
[ __ ] girl at the party and like been
flirting with her like
with the love of his life yesterday like
stupid they go from being like these
international wanted criminals to like
actual dumb teenagers like with like you
can't be both dumb teenage problems like
i mean i think literally the worst
decision they made the entire trip was
getting into a shipping crate
like so dangerous you could die yeah no
there
but everything was just like so stupid
like i
i can't how many times are they going to
find the treasure and leave it there
while they go back and find something
leave someone to stand guard while you
take him to the ambulance because he got
stung by a wasp right or
like
i just i can't also when
pope hopped on the back of rafe's truck
when rafe was driving the cross and
first he was dumping the body and then
i can't believe he had the element of
surprise it was just raf versus pope
like round three i guess they kept
calling it like okay so he lost the
fight whatever but when
rafe was dragging the body out to the
water why didn't pope just walk around
to the front and get in the car and
drive like no so the worst decisions
made of all time so i really was
enjoying the show but like
the worst decisions made of all time no
it's like frustrating because you want
to root for them but they're so dumb
like they should lose yeah like they're
not making smart decisions
no and i knew the sheriff was obviously
going to investigate ward but like he
can't just do that he's a very powerful
man you have to be very secretive make
sure the kids are right and he did right
by them in the end yeah he did
um
so okay but if they just had the
videotape
moronic it just all goes back to that so
when they finally found the cross and
that woman on the crutches
there's no there's supposed to be some
cloth in there that has like healing
powers uh it's so obvious that the cloth
is john b's bandana that's he's been
wearing around his neck i thought that
the whole time and then i saw other
people thinking that on tick tock like
it's so obvious
and there's a reason why he's been
acting like a lunatic for two years with
people with guns and and he's been fine
like that thing is protecting him that's
interesting and sarah had it around her
neck when she was in the bahamas like it
was protecting her no he gave it to her
on the boat because she got shot when
she wasn't wearing it
see
i but you think they had a bandanna back
i know i was thinking holy grail i was
just thinking like you just wore a
bandana like in terms of style it didn't
really make sense but john b's dad is
alive he said he knows where the cloth
is
of course it's john b's like there's no
way that it's not
i think they had bandanas in
one is across from or it could have been
like a uh you know a holy cloth but they
like tied at it tie-dyed it and stuff
just so that it would blend in with
modern society yeah no there's there's
something there and then i also saw a
conspiracy theory that say that that
limbery blonde woman with the crutches
is john b's mother
i'm going to say no they also didn't
didn't john bee's dad whose spoiler is
alive at the end didn't he say you have
to help my son
didn't he say my son
i don't remember we should go back a
month yeah well i'll send you the tick
tock that said that it's john b's mom i
saw that on tick tock i mean sure that
would like be another added element but
i think that just the dad being alive is
is enough i feel like topper did not get
like enough screen time like he's a good
character he is oh but it's just really
hard because when i see sarah and topper
i just want them to be together but it's
like obviously sarah and john b are end
game no for the show yeah but like i i
don't know i'm not aboard that ship uh
whatsoever i think they're actually
really toxic and they make the worst
decisions and they always are getting in
trouble together it's just so crazy that
like the pogues like are
you know
they wanted so badly
and they lost the gold and the cross
no and now they're on some island like
gonna make their own surfboards with by
the way i love that that woman from the
bahamas made a return on the boat cleo
like that was a great moment that was a
great moment but yeah like what's the
plan and their parents like think that
they're dead and they're just having the
time of their life it was giving me
vibes of the society
like when they go back and they show how
like the parents back in the society
think everyone's dead
yeah it's not an alternate universe but
it's just reminding me like how are they
gonna get i guess maybe they'll build a
boat on the island then they can like
row actually no they have a boat they
need to build ores because they don't
have fuel right right right
it was just like a little too silly they
did a compass
do they have anything that we're gonna
make surfboards out of what
wood
yeah
a wooden surfboard moronic
it's just the whole like the show was
really good and actually season two was
pretty good considering season one like
we have a new treasure
all this stuff that that's exciting but
um
there's just so many holes and it's it's
so hard to root for them it's like i can
only suspend disbelief about these
teenagers living in north carolina for
so long yeah you know yeah um
okay but i'm glad you watch it yeah i'm
glad i watched it too the only other
thing that i did this weekend was i read
a book called it happened one summer it
was the book that margot was going to
choose for the redheads but didn't she
chose something like a little bit more
serious instead so it's like y-a
romance and honestly it was really good
like it was a really good love story at
first i was like it's actually the setup
of a hallmark movie but like
the author did a good job of like
building the relationship and the love
you know and just like it was really
cute but it was like really raunchy
so it's called it happened of course if
margaret was going to show his name is
wrong
than the usual cinch's choice so um i
but i would recommend it i really
enjoyed like the love story i thought it
was very
believable and it was like a cute setup
cute yeah my list of books to read is
just getting so long i can't read and so
i've been reading so long like i'm just
i'm not in a reading place i'll get
there soon maybe you just need the right
book no i think it's also just like a
seasonal thing like i don't read in the
summer unless i'm like at the beach but
like i'm never at the beach i'm always
at the beach i'm just here next city
so um
yeah that's our show right that's our
show the tv recaps were real i hope you
guys enjoyed all that tonight starts
bachelor in paradise and honestly like
i don't know if i could do it for real
i want to do it i just wish i had more
time after i need a month
yeah
oh
yeah i'll think about it
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennium morning
show where we deliver the fafsa stories
that you need to know every monday
through friday on youtube so if you're
watching this on youtube please feel
free to subscribe give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcasts can be found
so it's spotify itunes stitcher public
radio i heart radio cast box all the
places so whenever you listen to a
podcast find us the morning toast leave
a five star view about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are the society
season two if you're still listening
make sure to leave an emoji of a
sailboat in on our obx on our instagram
from today have a great day you guys bye